You never know how long it’s going to take
to get a film’s story just right, and even
if the script is sound, things could change
over the course of a project’s development.
A movie isn’t truly finalized until the
director is in the editing bay, working hard
on assembling the finished cut that will be
shown in theaters.
This means that several scenes or sequences
can be left on the cutting room floor, but
in some cases, some of the actors aren’t
safe.
Even after months of hard work, there’s
always a possibility an A-lister misses out
on a film.
Here are 10 popular movies that wasted a famous
actor’s role.
If you like what you see, be sure to like
this video and subscribe to our channel.
Batman V Superman: Dawn of Justice
When Jenna Malone was cast in Zack Snyder’s
Batman V Superman, DC fans blew up the Internet
with theories and speculation about whom she’d
play.
After all the talk, it was surprising when
Malone never showed up in the theatrical cut
of the film.
Her part was reinstated for the 3-hour ultimate
edition on the Blu-ray, but it was far from
what fans had hoped.
Instead of Batgirl or some other important
character, Malone was simply a lab tech that
Lois Lane visited during her investigation.
As disappointing as that might be, her scenes
helped clear some muddled questions about
the original version, so her content was still
valuable.
The Lord of the Rings: The Return of the King
Sauron is the main baddie of the Lord of the
Rings trilogy, but he received a substantial
amount of help from the dark wizard Saruman.
The title The Two Towers refers to that duo’s
respective homes in Mordor and Isengard.
They made for a nefarious pair, so it was
a little odd when Saruman was absent from
the grand finale, The Return of the King.
At least in the theatrical version, the character
has no real conclusion in the story.
Director Peter Jackson cut Christopher Lee’s
scenes out as a creative decision and planned
to reinsert them later on the DVD.
The actor was none too pleased by this move
and skipped the film’s premiere.
The Amazing Spider-Man 2
The Amazing Spider-Man series showcased Peter
Parker’s romance with Gwen Stacey, but originally
the sequel was going to give the web head
two love interests to keep track of.
Actress Shailene Woodley was cast as the fiery
red head Mary Jane Watson and shot some scenes
for the movie.
She was on set for the span of a few days,
filming material with Andrew Garfield to set
up further development in sequels.
Eventually, director Marc Webb removed this
subplot entirely in an effort to streamline
the main story.
This was probably for the best, since a major
element of Amazing Spider-Man 2 was Gwen’s
death.
Bridesmaids
Paul Rudd usually plays a charming, easygoing
guy that you’d like to get a beer with,
but actors are always looking for ways to
challenge themselves.
Rudd thought he had such a part when he was
cast in the hit comedy Bridesmaids.
His role was a small one – a real jerk of
a guy that Kristin Wiig goes out with when
she’s looking for a dating rebound.
Rudd excelled at playing against type, but
he was perhaps a little too good at it.
Early test screenings did not receive this
character fondly, and Rudd was ultimately
cut from the Oscar nominated film.
Maybe one day he’ll get to show his mean
side in a movie.
E.T.
– The Extra Terrestrial
Harrison Ford has several films to his name,
but among his most famous are his collaborations
with Steven Spielberg.
By the end of this decade, Ford will have
worked with the director on five Indiana Jones
movies, but the dynamic duo could have combined
forces for another one of Spielberg’s classics.
Ford was cast as Elliott’s school principal
in E.T., and shot some fun and amusing scenes
with Henry Thomas.
But when it came time to edit, Spielberg felt
they didn’t add much to the story and trimmed
them out.
E.T. went on to become one of the most beloved
family films ever made, so the director chose
wisely.
Life of Pi
Ang Lee’s Oscar winning adaptation of this
novel uses a framing device that involves
an adult Pi telling his incredible story of
survival to a journalist.
In the finished film, that character is played
by English actor Rafe Spall, but he wasn’t
the first one to have a stab at the role.
Originally, Lee cast former Spider-Man Tobey
Maguire, but later determined that Maguire
was too famous for amounted to a bit part
and would have distracted the audience from
the narrative.
Maguire stepped aside and made way for Spall,
whom Lee apparently had no issues with.
It would have been nice to see Maguire on
the screen again, but this was not the meatiest
role he could have taken.
Avengers: Age of Ultron
Earth’s Mightiest are the most famous characters
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, and their
popularity is rivaled by perhaps only villain
Loki.
Since his first appearance in 2011’s Thor,
the God of Mischief has become a standout
figure in the franchise, with Tom Hiddelston
reprising the role multiple times to many
fans’ delight.
He was the main antagonist in the first Avengers
movie, and while he wasn’t the focus of
the sequel, Joss Whedon had initially planned
for Loki to return.
Hiddelston shot a cameo for Thor’s dream
sequence, but it was cut because test audiences
thought Loki was the one controlling Ultron.
It made sense for the film, and Loki will
return in Thor: Ragnarok.
Black Mass
This true story crime drama was seen as Johnny
Depp’s comeback role, as he earned a Best
Actor nomination from the Screen Actors Guild
for his performance.
But Depp wasn’t the only big name who was
part of the project.
Tough girl Sienna Miller was cast to play
Bulger’s girlfriend Catherine Greig and
spent some time filming scenes with Depp.
But in post-production, director Scott Cooper
decided the film would be better off if Miller
was cut completely, feeling her removal would
narrow the scope of the sprawling narrative.
Some reviewers felt that Whitey’s character
lacked some depth, and perhaps those cut scenes
would have added some.
Maybe Cooper should have looked for something
else to ax?
The Good Dinosaur
Pixar is typically a lock for critically acclaimed
box office hits, but The Good Dinosaur is
a rare misstep in their filmography.
The movie was plagued by numerous production
difficulties, which caused the creative team
to overhaul the script.
Back in 2014, star John Lithgow commented
that everything had been “completely reimagined”
and the actors would have to re-record voice
over to fit the new material.
Unfortunately, some of the actors cast in
the initial version, like Lithgow and Neil
Patrick Harris, were unable to come back and
had to be replaced, meaning all their work
in the booth was for nothing.
Furious 7
Before she became Wonder Woman, Gal Gadot
was part of a different blockbuster franchise
– The Fast and the Furious.
She appeared as the character Gisele in three
installments and was supposed to return for
2015’s Furious 7.
Gadot filmed scenes where Gisele takes Letty
to the hospital after Letty is injured in
a car explosion, but those parts ended up
being edited out completely.
Gisele’s role in the monster hit was reduced
to archive footage from previous movies and
a still photograph, despite Gadot receiving
top billing on the project.
Fans enjoyed watching her, so it’s a shame
her final performance was cut.
These are just some of the actors who were
cut from their movies.
Which ones did we miss?
Let us know in the comments
below and be sure to subscribe to our channel
for more fun videos!